je vends mon iphone je reste là
[Musique]
non ça a été repris par les visiteurs
mais c'était le cri traditionnel des
chevaliers français
c'est exact
[Musique]
il faudrait vraiment qu'il se passe
beaucoup de catastrophes
il y à des prétendants qui sont reconnus
respectés par la république
mais enfin ça ne me paraît pas à l'ordre
du jour
[Musique]
à mon avis c'est le mexique parce que
c'est une américanisation qui y laissent
des mauvais souvenirs quand on se
souvient de wallis simpson la future
duchesse de windsor le fait si vous
voulez récemment que megan se comporte
comme si elle voulait rejouer le triste
rôle de diana et d'autre part le prince
harry y est venu aux funérailles de son
grand-père mais qui n'est pas resté le
lendemain pour le 95e anniversaire de la
reine sa grand mère
[Musique]
oui grâce à l'adn y compris l'adn du
prince philippe puisqu'on a pu établir
ainsi que la prétendue anastasia ne
pouvait pas être membre de la famille
romanov alors
on a à peu près tous retrouvés et il
faut saluer la russie de gorbatchev de
boris nsync avec beaucoup de courage
permis c'est d'en quête ses recherches
et une cérémonie à laquelle j'ai assisté
1900 cadre à 18 pour demander pardon
après les horreurs de la révolution et
c'était une belle leçon de courage
politique
[Musique]
je connais un peu puisque c'est notre
fille je suis très fier et très heureux
pour elle très heureux pour le louvre
elle a les compétences scientifiques
mais aussi humaine parce que l'a déjà
fait le louvre d'abu dhabi la réveiller
le musée d'orsay et de l'orangerie et
elle a une réputation internationale qui
me paraît 2
bon aloi elle est très joyeuse très
discrète elle travaille beaucoup et je
pense que le louvre ne peut être entre
de bonnes mains
[Musique]